SPEAK OF THE DHS SECRETARY
GRILLED BY SENATORS AND KIND OF
REVEALED HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY KNOW
THAT MUCH ABOUT HIS NEWLY HIRED
DISINFORMATION CZAR, DESPITE
CALLING HER QUALIFIED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SHE HAS CONSISTENTLY
MISINFORMED THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY AND
SPEND THE LIGHT THAT IT WAS
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
USE SOCIAL MEDIA TO LAUNDER
PROPAGANDA HERSELF.
>> WERE YOU AWARE OF THIS
INFORMATION WHEN YOU CHOSE HER?
>> I WAS NOT.
>> HOW COULD YOU NOT BE?
>> DID YOU DO ANY RESEARCH ON
OUR?
>> IS THE DEPARTMENT AWARE OF
HER TIKTOK VIDEOS?
>> SENATOR --
>> THEY ARE REALLY QUITE
PRECOCIOUS.
>> SENATOR, I WAS NOT.
>> HE'S SO FUNNY,
SENATOR KENNEDY.
20 G.O.P. LED STATES ARE
THREATENING TO SUE OVER THE
DISINFORMATION BOARD AND
REPUBLICANS MAKE AN ISSUE OVER
THE LACK OF VETTING FOR THE
CHIEF.
NEWLY UNCOVERED VIDEO SHOWS ARE
DISMISSING CONCERNS ABOUT A
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS IN
SCHOOLS.
>> CRITICAL RACE THEORY HAS
BECOME ONE OF THOSE HOT BUTTON
ISSUES THAT THE REPUBLICANS AND
OTHER DISTANT INFORMERS WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN DISINFORMATION FOR
PROFIT, THERE'S PLENTY OF MEDIA
OUTLETS THAT ARE MAKING MONEY
OFF OF THIS TOO.
IT IS NO DIFFERENT THAN ANY OF
THE OTHER HOT BUTTON ISSUES THAT
ALLOW DISINFORMATION TO
FLOURISH.
IT'S WEAPONIZING PEOPLES OF
MOTION.
LET ME START WITH YOU ON THIS.
WHAT I LOVED OF WHAT SHE SAID --
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF GETTING
EMOTIONAL, THERE'S A GOOD CHANCE
THAT SOMEONE IS JUST
MANIPULATING YOU.
SO JUST CALL YOURSELF DOWN AND
SAY, I'M BEING MANIPULATED COULD
NOT NOT GOING TO LET IT HAPPEN
TO ME BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE UP TO.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE OTHER STATEMENT WAS THE
REPUBLICANS AND OTHER DISTANT
INFORMERS, AS IF THERE WAS ALL
THERE.
WE THE REPUBLICANS ARE JUST
INFORMED.
AND ALL THOSE PARENTS THAT ARE
TESTING THE SCHOOL BOARD BECAUSE
THEY REALLY ARE IN IT FOR THE
PROFIT.
IT IS A DROOPING IRONY OF OUR
MOMENT THAT THE PERSON IN CHARGE
OF THE GOVERNMENT ON
DISINFORMATION IS HERSELF AT
THIS INFORMANT.
INTENTIONALLY ON ONE SIDE OF THE
AISLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT HIRED HER AND
KNEW EXACTLY WHO SHE WAS.
AND KNOW EXACTLY WHAT YOUR
POLITICAL INCLINATIONS AND
INSTINCTS ARE.
SHE SAID DO YOU SEEK HIM,
THIRTYSOMETHING D.C. CREATURE
THAT WENT TO GEORGETOWN AND THAT
SAME WAY THAT BUBBLE THINGS,
WHICH IS ONE SIDE OF THE AISLE
IS TO SOME FORMANTS, THE REST
ARE THE ELITES.
COMING FOR THE MAGA CROWD ABOUT
WHAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
THEY WANTED IT THAT WAY,
THANKFULLY SHE TWEETS AND TIKTOK
MORE OR LESS AND KNOWS ABOUT IT.
MAYBE SHE WON'T GET THIS
POSITION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SUPPOSED TO KEEP US
SAFE.
AND INSTEAD IT IS FACILITATING
OPEN BORDERS IN THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND CREATING A GOVERNMENT
TO CENSOR SPEECH OF CITIZENS.
>> THIS IS AN UNFAIR CRITICISM
OF HER.
>> NOW.
IF THERE WASN'T EVIDENCE FOR IT
LIKE A TIKTOK I COULD WATCH OR A
TWEET I COULD READ AND
EVERYTHING IS RECORDED NOW AND
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE CONSCIOUS OF
THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE PART OF A DIGITAL
GENERATION, THAT IS SOMETHING
YOU OFTEN FIND OUT TOO LATE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING SHE'S BEEN
DOING AS A PROFESSIONAL AND THAT
IS PERFECTLY FINE.
MAYBE YOU ARE NOT SUITED FOR
THIS PARTICULAR POSITION.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE ISN'T
ROOM FOR YOU IN THE WORLD AND TO
HAVE ANOTHER GREAT JOB.
BUT THIS PHYSICAL QUESTION OF
WHEN MAYOR ARCUS IS GOING TO
SAY, IT'S NOT WORTH IT FOR ME
ANYMORE.
>> THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY WANT THIS PERSON AND THIS
IS PERSON IS GOING TO END UP A
LITTLE TOO EXTREME.
MAYBE IF WE SACRIFICE THIS ONE
FOR THIS ONE, WE WILL GET THIS
THING WE WANT.
MAYBE THAT IS WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
I BELIEVE THAT HE HAD NOT SEEN
THE MARY POPPINS VIDEO.
SOMEONE ON HIS TEAM I'M SURE HAD
AN INSTINCT IT WAS GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM.
MAYBE THAT IS AN INDICATION OF
KNOWING WHAT'S WRONG WITH OUR
TIMES AS WELL.
PEOPLE DO NOT THINK AHEAD AS TO
WHAT THE RESPONSE IS GOING TO BE
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
THIS HAPPENS CONSTANTLY RUNNING
ABSURD CANDIDATES WHO HAVE CRAZY
PASTS.
THEY THINK, OH, THEY WON'T FIND
OUT ABOUT THAT OR WHATEVER THEY
WERE DOING.
>> I WASN'T TALKING ABOUT YOU
PARTICULARLY.
>> I KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE THIS
KIND OF BACKGROUND, JANINE.
THERE'S NOT THAT MANY STAND-UP
FOLKS WHO WERE DYING FOR THESE
KIND OF JOBS I DON'T THINK.
OR EVEN PERHAPS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNMENT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE THERE AND THIS?
>> EVERY TIME HE SPEAKS, I SAY
TO MYSELF, THERE IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF A MAN WHO LIES EVERY
TIME HE OPENS HIS MOUTH.
LIKE A MOTHER BORDERS ARE
SECURE.
IF 18,000 PEOPLE COME THROUGH A
DAY, IF WE LOOK AT TITLE 42, IT
WILL BE FINE.
THE MAN HAS NEVER SAID A TRUTH
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
I DON'T BELIEVE HIM AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT, I MUST TELL YOU, IF
ANYONE IN ANY PLACE IN THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S GOT TO BE A VETTING
OF AN INDIVIDUAL, IT HAS GOT TO
BE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., WHEN YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT A WHITE HOUSE
OR ADMINISTRATION.
THIS ISN'T LIKE IN HIGH SCHOOL
THEY ARE HIRING A GUY FIVE YEARS
AGO THAT GOT DRUNK OR SOMETHING.
A DISINFORMATION BOARD OR
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO CALL IT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN THIS GUY -- SHE
IS EMINENTLY QUALIFIED.
NOT QUALIFIED CUP OF THE
OPPOSITE.
SHE HAS PROVEN THAT SHE IS NOT
QUALIFIED.
THIS IS WHAT I HATE ABOUT
POLITICS.
I HATE THE FACT THAT PEOPLE
DON'T BELIEVE IN RIGHT AND WRONG
AND TRUTH AND JUSTICE ANYMORE.
IT IS ABOUT POWER AND WINNING
AND LYING ON YOUR WAY TO GET A
NET.
MAKES ME THINK OF YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
>> DHS SHOULD STAND FOR DOM HIRE
SECRETARY.
HE CLAIMS THAT HE COULD NOT
DISCLOSE HOW HE HIRED HER AS IF
THEIR HIRING PROCESS IS SACRED.
DOESN'T THE GOVERNMENT REQUIRE
BUSINESSES TO KIND OF MAKE THEIR
PRACTICES TRANSPARENT?
THIS GUY DOESN'T KNOW WHO IS
RUNNING THE BOARD AND HE DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW WHO'S RUNNING THE
BORDER.
SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
PRETTY GOOD.
THAT'S NORMALLY I WOULD SAY A
HARMLESS PERSON.
A WALKING HARDWARE TREND.
SHE TWEETS ABOUT THAT.
CRT IS A RIGHT-WING FEAR
ATTRACTED.
LAPTOP IS RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
THESE ALL GOOD -- THE YEAR DOWN
MY PROBLEM IS NOT THAT IT'S
LATE, DOESN'T MAKE HER A BAD
PERSON.
IT DOESN'T MAKE HER A BAD
THE PROBLEM IS SHE'S NOT
UNBIASED.
IF YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING SHE
TALKS ABOUT AND BELIEVES IN COBO
SHE IS SWAYED BY WHAT GETS IN
TOUCH AND IN HER WORLD.
IF THEY ACTUALLY KEEP THIS
ACTUAL BOARD, THEY HAVE TO
REALLY TRY TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO FIND SOMEBODY WITH
A CENTRIST PERSPECTIVE, SOMEBODY
THAT THEY MIGHT NOT FLIGHT, YOU
KNOW?
SOMEBODY THAT PASSES YOU ALL 50%
OF THE TIME AND DOESN'T TICK YOU
OFF THE OTHER 50%.
WE KNOW THAT THERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUT THERE.
I WOULD USE SOMEBODY LIKE BILL
MARR IS AN EXAMPLE, BECAUSE HALF
THE TIME I WANT TO THROW
SOMETHING AT THE TEAM E.
THAT'S REALLY BRAVE OR REALLY
AMAZING.
YOU COULD TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
SIDE SHE'S GOING TO COME DOWN ON
JUST BY READING YOUR TWEETS.
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS MADE IT VERY
TRANSPARENT.
I DON'T THINK HE KNOWS WHO I AM.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> A NEWSPAPER THAT SOMEONE
WHO'S NEUTRAL.
THAT IS WHAT I NEED.
YOU POINTED OUT, HE WOULD
DISCUSS THE INNER WORKINGS OF
THE HIGHER CLASS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
HE CAN'T TELL YOU HOW HE HIDES
THE PERSON BECAUSE HE HIRED THEM
WITH THEIR MONEY.
ANYWAY, I HAD TO COME OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS VP AT ODDS
AGAIN ACCORDING TO SOME NEW
REPORTING.
THIS TIME OVER AN ISS